[Musica]
margot a sette anni e vive a roma tre
anni fa era sulle spalle della sua mamma
tra le migliaia di persone scese in
piazza per il primo sciopero globale per
il clima non capiva cosa ci facesse lì
tutta quella gente così come fanno i
bambini aveva riempito i grandi di
domande ma le risposte che aveva
ricevuto l'avevano spaventata da quel
momento aveva iniziato ad avere paura
aveva paura di morire di caldo aveva
paura di soffrire la fame e la sete ma
soprattutto aveva paura di annegare
l'idea che il mare si stesse alzando la
spaventava più di ogni altra cosa
chiedeva continuamente quand'è che
sarebbe arrivato fino a casa sua tonino
vive a latina ed è un contadino di anni
ne ha 82 ha sempre amato e vissuto della
terra tonino si informa ed è sempre in
prima linea per ogni battaglia sociale e
racconta con solennità con gravità
muovendo le mani scolpita dalla fatica
che è tutto cambiato che produrre è
diventato difficile che l'acqua
scarseggia che davvero complicato
rimanere a lavorare quella terra e che
domani sarà impossibile
debora e di genova una città che ha
visto tante volte che non riesce più a
contarle alluvioni devastanti ha visto
la preoccupazione il terrore negli occhi
della gente non può dimenticarlo sacchi
d'italia è il sesto paese al mondo per
vittime da eventi climatici estremi e sa
che in questa triste contabilità ci sono
persone che conosceva marika che sono io
è nata e cresciuta in basilicata
proprio a fianco di uno dei più grandi
poli estrattivi d'europa sarà per questo
che è diventata un attivista ambientale
ha toccato con mano quanto sono grandi
le responsabilità delle compagnie che
bruciano carbone petrolio e gas
quanti danni producono sui territori
il clima ma sa benissimo che da sole non
faranno ciò che è giusto che tocca alle
istituzioni pubbliche porre dei limiti
tonino debora e marika hanno firmato un
foglio margot ha chiesto ai suoi
genitori di farlo un foglio pieno di
altre firme con il con il quale hanno
preso una decisione storica citare in
giudizio
lo stato italiano perché per portarlo
alla sbarra per accusarlo di una colpa
grave quella di ignorare nei fatti la
più grande minaccia che pende sui
destini di tutti gli esseri viventi del
pianeta la catastrofe climatica ma
tonino marika margot e gli altri 200
nuovi su quel foglio non sono matti non
sono i primi e non saranno gli ultimi a
cercare ogni strada per indurre chi deve
a ridurre le emissioni di gas serra che
significa prendere delle decisioni
urgenti precise radicali oggi le climate
litigation come si chiamano le cause
legali sui cambiamenti climatici
in tutto il mondo sono più di 2.000 in
più di 45 paesi appena cinque anni fa
quando le nazioni unite le hanno censite
per la prima volta erano
884 in 24 paesi
un fenomeno in espansione
continua perché di fronte agli allarmi
della scienza e di fronte
all'insufficienza delle politiche messe
in campo sono sempre di più i cittadini
le cittadine i gruppi di giovani di
associazioni che stanno portando in
tribunale i responsabili dell'emergenza
climatica e la cosa bella è che in molti
moltissimi casi stanno vincendo hanno
vinto in olanda
correva l'anno 2019 qualche giorno prima
di natale in una fredda mattina
d'inverno nelle aule della corte suprema
i giudici olandesi
contribuivano a scrivere un pezzo di
storia e condannavano lo stato a ridurre
le emissioni in linea con gli impegni
che aveva preso era la prima vittoria in
europa una vittoria destinata a segnare
un percorso
dopo di allora
le ragioni della società civile hanno
vinto in francia in irlanda in
repubblica ceca e ancora in germania
dove nel 2021 un anno fa una storica
decisione della corte costituzionale
tedesca chiamata in causa da un gruppo
di ragazzi ha annullato la legge
climatica nazionale perché essendo poco
ambiziosa violava i diritti delle future
generazioni
ma non è soltanto nel nord del mondo che
i tribunali sono diventati terreno di
battaglia climatica anche in paesi
lontani per geografie per tradizioni
giuridiche ad esempio in pakistan in
india in colombia alcune vittorie che
erano impensabili fino ad alcuni anni fa
stanno ridisegnando la road map per la
giustizia climatica e nel 2021 è
arrivato il momento dell'italia
un'associazione ecologista indipendente
a sud ha lanciato l'idea e il cuore
oltre l'ostacolo ma questa avventura si
sono uniti subito in tanti e tante 24
associazioni
193 persone tra essi 17 bambini come
margò l'hanno definita la causa del
secolo ed è diventata a sud ed altri
contro italia la prima grande causa
collettiva contro lo stato per difendere
il territorio e chi lo abita dai
cambiamenti climatici
cosa chiediamo al giudice
innanzitutto di dichiarare che il nostro
paese ha una responsabilità precisa
conosce il pericolo che i cambiamenti
climatici comportano sa benissimo quanto
è vulnerabile il territorio del nostro
paese un paese a bagno nel mediterraneo
ma nonostante sappia nonostante dichiari
nei fatti non agisce i suoi obiettivi di
riduzione sono al di sotto di ogni
ragionevole prudenza per questo allo
star giudice chiediamo anche un'altra
cosa
gli chiediamo di condannare il nostro
paese a moltiplicare i suoi sforzi di
riduzione a triplicarli e di farlo non
solo tenendo conto degli impegni che ha
preso firmando l'accordo di parigi ma
anche le sue responsabilità storiche che
gli impongono di fare di più e meglio
dei paesi che non hanno responsabilità
perché hanno emesso poco o nulla e che
comunque si trovano in questo momento
loro malgrado a pagare un prezzo
altissimo
i cambiamenti climatici sono così sono
un moltiplicatore di minacce sono un
amplificatore di disuguaglianze che
colpisce con più ferocia chi non ha
colpa o chi non ha mezzi che siano
comunità remote paesi del sud del mondo
oppure le generazioni che verranno
ma di fronte a questa intollerabile
ingiustizia
c'è in campo un grande grandissimo
movimento globale il movimento per la
giustizia climatica
c'è un grido di battaglia che forse
avete sentito in tv o avete visto sui
cartelloni delle manifestazioni che da
greta thun berg in poi hanno riempito le
piazze di migliaia di città di tutto il
mondo è climate justice
ma che cos'è la giustizia climatica
innanzitutto è un grido di battaglia ma
è anche una lente per leggere questo
mondo diseguale per provare a ripararlo
rivendicare giustizia climatica
significa ribadire fino alla stanchezza
che i cambiamenti climatici non sono
solo un fenomeno ecologico ma che hanno
profondissime implicazioni sociali
immigratorie politiche economiche e
lavorative
significa ribadire
evidenziare che i rapporti di forza
gli equilibri di potere o meglio i
disequilibri di potere tra gli stati
sono strumentali a mantenere immutate le
disuguaglianze e i privilegi significa
esigere l'applicazione del sacrosanto
principio di equità che impone che chi
non ha responsabilità sia aiutato
tutelato ad affrontare gli impatti ormai
inevitabili ma contribuire alla
giustizia climatica passa anche per
tante decisioni che prendiamo ogni
giorno ad esempio cosa dove quanto
comprare quanta carne mangiare e se
mangiarla come spostarci quali battaglie
e campagne e sostenere chi votare e chi
non votare ovvero rende prima di tutto
cittadine e cittadini pensanti e
consumatrici e consumatori critici
battersi per la giustizia climatica
battersi per un clima stabile sicuro non
è una lotta soltanto ecologista vuol
dire battersi per la giustizia sociale
per l'uguaglianza di genere per la
democrazia vuol dire contestare un
modello socio economico che produce
disuguaglianze e di devastazione
ambientale e significa lottare per
scelte per politiche strutturali e
coraggiose nei tribunali come nelle
piazze scelte destinate a cambiare il
modo in cui guardiamo a noi stessi su
questo pianeta non più come padroni di
tutto ma come parte del tutto perché è
il sistema che deve cambiare non il
clima
[Musica]
grazie a tutti a tutti
[Applauso]